♫ One two ♫
- I feel like there's like a glass ceiling
for women, because I've hit it.
If you skate and you rip
then you should just get what you deserve,
if like skateboarding is
supposed to be for everybody.
If we do actually want any
form of equality or space,
like, we're gonna have to be
the ones who create that space.
(electronic music)
My name is Lacey Baker and I'm
a professional skateboarder.
I discovered skateboarding
when I was really really young,
at like two years old.
I was in foster care at that time
and I would watch my foster brothers skate
a mini ramp, and I just
was like immediately obsessed.
Like I was like I have to do this.
I started competing
when I was 11 years old.
When I was 22, I skated
the 2014 X Games in Austin
and that's the year I won the gold.
With women in skateboarding,
there's like a subculture
within a subculture.
The skate industry like just doesn't care
about women skating.
It's not equal.
For example, like, there is
this skateboard contest series
which didn't used to include women in it
but it just started to.
However, the prize for
first place is 30 grand,
and like for the guys
first place is 200 grand.
I feel like it should
be equal because we work
just as hard as the guys.
Meow Skateboards is a
company that was created
to, like, support women in skateboarding.
I do my own board graphics,
like I do a lot of
the other girls' board graphics.
And like, it's rad because
it's, like, skater owned,
and it's, like, for us,
and it's, like, by us.
So it's like, there's
nothing corporate about it.
And it feels like that's
how it's supposed to be.
Even if nothing comes of,
like, having a skate career
or like, anything like that,
like, I still have skating.
And, like, I believe in being yourself,
and, like, just doing
whatever the fuck you want,
and that's what skating is supposed to be.